los franceses volvieron a decir presente
en esta quinta jornada de manifestación
contra la reforma pensional aquí en
París según cifras de los sindicatos
participaron 300.000 personas en una
manifestación que terminó aquí en la
plaza de Italia son cifras de
participación en todo el país que están
por debajo de lo que venía registrándose
anteriormente pero era algo que se
esperaba porque hay una parte del país
que está en vacaciones escolares sin
embargo lo importante del día de hoy
para los sindicatos no eran tanto las
cifras de participación sino en realidad
seguir mostrando que los franceses
siguen saliendo a la calle para
manifestarse contra esta reforma que
consideran completamente injusta y
además era también la última opción o el
último momento para que la calle pudiera
ejercer de alguna manera presión sobre
los diputados de la asamblea nacional
que tienen hasta este viernes a la media
noche para terminar de examinar el texto
del proyecto de ley ahora vienen dos
semanas de pausa en cuanto a
manifestaciones pero luego viene ese muy
sonado ya
siete de marzo en cuando todos los
sindicatos han llamado a bloquear el
país en lo que se espera sea una jornada
negra para Francia